ta carole nous allons maintenant
rejoindre paul bocuse depuis le 8e salon
des métiers de bouche paul bocuse
bonsoir bonsoir
donc nous avons entendu un bonne chance
à carole bonne chance aussi à d'autres
d'autres participants d'autres
concurrents en tout cas ceux qui vont
attaquer dès demain le bocuse d'or vous
pouvez nous rappeler en deux mots ce
qu'est le bocuse d'or
oui vous savez il ya dix ans on a créé
ce concours justement pour retrouver une
certaine identité culinaire de la
cuisine qui a hier perdait on perdait
une certaine identité
tout le monde fait pareil aujourd'hui on
impose le produit et chaque cuisinier
doit culminer takieddine d'après son
pays c'est ça qui est important
là le produit imposer je crois que les
participants auront à se battre avec du
cuissot et du cabillaud c'est ça oui et
un gars bio qui viennent norvège du
frais c'est un gars bio qui est un
poisson de passage des migrateurs et
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire et
les jambons sont donc les jambon d'aoste
des jambons très bon très rond de 8 à 10
kilos est-ce qu'il ya parmi tous ses
concurrents quelques quelques-uns l'on
peut dire de vos anciens élèves en tout
quatre anciens adeptes
oui vous savez aujourd'hui 22 pays et
dans ses vingt-deux pays je connais
aussi bien d autres alliant des
américains je crois que ça va être un
concours formidable d'ailleurs il ya un
public extraordinaire
aujourd'hui il y avait le look la finale
des pâtissiers et c'était quelque chose
de très impressionnant et lemaitre n'a
pas peur de se faire dépasser par ses
élèves maintenant
or vous savez oui pourquoi pas c'est ça
qui est formidable dans la compétition
dure deux jours un box dans sa doublure
de jeu au oui on dit que pour les
cuisiniers il faut se préparer un peu
comme des sportifs
oui bien sûr ils se sont entraînés
faisons entraîné à l'école des arts
culinaires l'écurie qui se vont
entraîner chez monsieur marcon et puis
il ya surtout à des prix intéressants
c'est ça qui est formidable
alors s'ils sont aussi intéressantes dit
huska alors bien sûr il ya déjà quinze
mille dollars pour le premier dix mille
dollars pour le deuxième
8000 $ et après des compression de césar
un bronze en or en argent et en bronze
puisqu'il fait aussi il va ya voir s'il
y a peu lourd il aura son poids de
champagne de champagne boom et je crois
qu'ils vont quand même faire la fête
est ce que ce genre de manifestation
comme celle qui porte votre nom comme le
bocuse d'or existe dans d'autres pays il
ya d'autres pays on célèbre autant la
gastronomie non je crois que c'est un
des groupes plus grands concours qui
existe
il ya des concours différents mais là
ont pris vie livre vraiment le produit
et je crois que c'est ça qui est
important
est ce que c'est un succès pour vous
cette année le salon compte plus de 1000
exposants il ya deux ans il y en avait 1
900 et parmi les 1000 exposants cette
année il ya plus de 200 étrangers
la cuisine est une norme internationale
oui et puis vous savez ce qui est
formidable c'est que ça remplit nos
maisons tous les restaurants et tous les
hôtels de lyon son plein je crois que
c'est ça c'est un but formidable c'est
marcher les affaires voilà c'est jusqu'à
mercredi ailleurs expliqué au coude mais
s'ils allaient bon appétit merci c'est
la fin